there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock
hey it's episode 155 yeah this is
supposed to be a pretty brutal one I
don't know much about this saying this
one involves lots of like poodle talk
tortured yes this was one this was
actually a serial killer that I didn't
know a great deal about I had heard of
him but I didn't really know that much
about him but this was also a topic
request I can't remember he requested it
because it was a long time ago yeah but
this is Robert Bob Varela otherwise
known as the Kansas City butcher or the
collector the collector yeah yeah and
we've been doing a lot of serial killers
and true crime lately because that's
what people of a requesting yeah so we
haven't done paranormal but we'll get
back on paranormal soon yeah and other
things historical mysteries because I
like doing that stuff too but you know I
feel bad because sometimes we get so
many requests for like different true
crime cases and it's like and I want to
get around to all of them but yeah true
crimes probably one of the biggest
segments or one of the biggest demands
online it does seem like I mean it seems
like a lot of the top podcasts and stuff
like better well there's a there's a lot
of paranormal out there already you know
most of it not very good so you know we
covered a lot of the main stuff yeah I
feel like we covered a lot of like the
big main topics yeah paranormal stuff I
mean you know there's always other
things we'll get back to it like I you
know there's still some that UFO stuff
going on with it with the the Navy yeah
and the military coming out saying that
yeah we see stuff and then I've been
listening to some of those pilots who
witnessed it you know now I'm take tack
UFOs and [ __ ] like that and it there's
something to it I even saw the videos
probably locked onto something moving
down at a high rate of speed close to
the surface of the water I don't know if
it was a cruise missile or what but it
moving awful fast and I didn't see any
kinda heat signature coming out of the
back where there'd be a rocket or a jet
propelled a little dot moving fast yeah
and you got a missile lock on it well
wasn't a missile lock it was some kind
of hopper is an optical lock you know
they have pods underneath the bottom of
the aircraft they might be inside now
you could get an optical lock on
something and everybody you can see it
in the team you know they can share the
data and stuff you know they you see
yeah far away you know moving objects
and it was something down there he got a
lock on it
we'll take that flying around yeah it
looked like a little dot you know and it
must and they said it was going
hypersonic you know in a straight line -
so you're not talking about a bullet or
a projectile it was something flying
you're pretty weird yeah well we'll have
to do like oh yeah about that one of
these days yeah well you will have to
collect some of the some of the best new
stuff that they have yeah we'll see
baby cookie just came in the room in
case she goes by the door but it's not
poltergeist it's like she just ran in
here the door open and then then she
jumped up behind the laptop so if the
camera starts to move you'll know why
cuz her little butt is gonna be skewed
yeah I'm just kicking off with it with
the Google car drinking really yeah we
did record some stuff earlier but stuff
yeah we recorded the stuff this
afternoon I was sober because we didn't
want to do it was like 3:00 or 4:00 in
the afternoon
I'm just car tonight though now we're
gonna show 70 style show for Merv
Griffin man for all the gifts you're
evader killer
the guests are drinking Merv is drinking
everybody at home is drinking you know
cookies not drinking though no she's now
doing it she's playing with her mint toy
was just right out of the damn Tarantino
movies way really was gonna do a little
hullabaloo dance with yeah yeah yeah so
alright so before we get into the main
topic and everyone gets all depressed
and bummed out because this is kind of a
rough topic um didn't somebody on
YouTube asked about our tattoos
yeah and didn't we say that we should
say something about them yeah okay well
you know what you guys all right well
basically this one okay well I'll get
into this later but um actually let me
do this one first I'm like looking at
the camera like I'm stupid all right so
this one is clearly Anubis you know yeah
and I just got that one because I always
was I mean ever since I was a kid I was
super into Egyptian mythology yeah and I
particularly always liked the mythology
about Anubis like weighing your heart
against the feather like you know the
thing like the judgment see if you get
to go to the good heaven place or to bad
place so I just always like that plus I
always just thought he was like kick-ass
and cool-looking that's about pretty
much the only there's no no deeper
meaning to it now this one this one here
what started off as owl it actually yeah
like up here I actually had my first
tattoo which was like a really little
like a tribal looking barn owl and I'd
had it for so long that and it was so
thick and black that it started to fade
and like all the lines that run together
so we um knew a guy named Jacob well we
still know him we just haven't seen him
in a long time
he's celebrity I'm Colette in Colombia
actually yeah seeing him show up still
look like the devil he's cool guy yeah
he's cool guy he does all those kind of
like a suspension shows with like they
put the hooks through your back and you
don't talk that way yeah yeah he's kind
of like famous in Colombia and he's also
a tattoo artist he was a he was an army
guy - he was a sniper yeah that's right
so me a lot in common when he was here
but he married a friend of ours but then
they broke up me way back on yeah so he
lived here for a little while but he was
also a tattoo artist so I told him and
he was a really good artist so I said
well I want something on this arm to
cover that up and you know can you just
like make something that's sort of
around the alla' theme but I just
basically let him draw whatever he
wanted and just let him put it on there
so I actually I got this tattoo done all
in one session normally they don't do
that normally they would do the outline
and then you'd go back and get all the
color but yeah
than the house is now yeah not quite
well you did all the all the outlines
he's professional and then he was like
wall are you okay like you wanna fit I
was like yeah I might as well I don't
know when the hell you're gonna get back
down here again do the rest of it so I
sat there for 11 yeah we were talking
and you fell asleep
his wife fell asleep yeah and I was just
sitting there I thought maybe I was
gonna get some work done but ma was too
late yeah he wasn't here beyond that but
yeah I really really like this I mean
eventually I'd like to kind of get the
whole arm done and get this whole arm
done I honestly you know what I've often
dreamed of it's like I just never have
the money to do it I've always wanted a
back piece that was based on Edgar Allan
Poe's mask of the Red Death yeah like
with the clock and the thing and
everything it's I would [ __ ] love
that no like I said I said that would
cost like a zillion dollars and I stole
the money yeah but I've always wanted
one my dad use a board want to see him I
guess this is actually like see planks
in this is actually like three different
tattoos I got this one on on a one-day
pass in the middle of basic training or
at the end we were going from basic
training I think it was know right
before graduation that's what it was
that was right outside San Hill I was
drunk when I got that one done just the
truth I won't marry me and then several
years after that when I was in the
hundred first I got this one this is a
barracks tattoo actually and then when I
joined a recon platoon I actually they
put recon right there on the top of it
it was another barracks tattoo I didn't
realize you had them done three separate
times yes three separate times it just
started adding on to it yeah for some
reason I got you it was just like to
know this was back in the 90s you know I
mean estándares were lower for tattoos
back there for no time I they were they
were smaller and the whole idea having
sleeves and [ __ ] really didn't wasn't
around so we would just they were calm
you know I army tattoos and this era was
kind of like a [ __ ] prison tattoo
really that's a lot of times that's what
funny like because it wasn't that long
ago that people like still looked yes at
you if you had tattoos like you were
some kind of criminal or circuits
breaker yeah they were kind of you know
I remember back in the time when I got
this when my buddy went out got one of
the predator and it looked [ __ ]
fantastic I was like damn I should've
got something like that why didn't I get
that again some [ __ ] like that but I
don't know I probably maybe one day if I
ever get around to it just kind of have
that all blended into a like a short
sleeve or something yeah he was gonna do
it for me yeah man Oh crazy just do what
you want with it putting it out is he's
such a good artist and like I just I
trust ya and I just I just said do like
an American military theme you know he
would he's he was of course you know he
was ex-military
he loved the American army he loved all
kind of military history so you know
he's the right man for the job realizes
yeah it's good great but he didn't get
you know you took up all the time then
the next next day yeah next day we
didn't really see him after that doing
not really maybe a couple times yeah I
think worst a few months after yeah they
weren't very very long but yeah I was
gonna say it's interesting when I got my
first tattoo the one that this covered
up it was still the 1990s and I got it
done in Daytona which of course is like
a big biker hangout so there was a
tattoo shop just right around the corner
from my grandma's house and so like I
went over there and had it done and even
then like the big fat biker guy that did
the tattoo they were trying to like
convince me to not get the tattoo on my
arm because this was the 1990s early
1990s and you know he was like oh well
people think things about girls that
have tattoos on their arms yeah and I
was like now everybody has them now
everybody has them but so I just think
that's really fun although I thought it
was funny that he said that at the time
he was like a lot hotter with like girls
gay guys and everything have a man you
know that's I don't have like super
effeminate transsexuals
they got [ __ ] soul sleeves back in
our days you didn't you just didn't see
the see [ __ ] like that if you had the
whole sleeve you were probably a junkie
trying to hide [ __ ] track mark it was
unusual to see it when we were growing
up yeah you're like what the hell yeah I
mean I always thought they were cool but
yeah do you see him you just didn't see
and you for sure didn't see like just
regular looking people
suit like walking down with like full
biker [ __ ] on their necks and stuff you
didn't say that bad bikers ex-service
people [ __ ] military people and
ex-military guys that's who had them
gangsters yeah like I said you saw him
in Daytona because it was like a biker
yeah place cuz you know especially
during like Biketoberfest [ __ ] but yeah
then I got teenyboppers with that [ __ ]
well now like now I pretty much
everybody we now has at least one yeah
and several people we know have multiple
yeah they're like you know I never
really saw him as a priority though you
know I'm like that's the thing it sucks
it's like I really like him and I want
more but I just never have extra money
like and especially like this [ __ ] that
I'm imagining the time to you gotta sit
for a long time and they do it all at
once
well yeah that's why I take MBAs Joe
head I said I'm just gonna say here for
11 hours and do this [ __ ] because I'm
itchy striking for several days yeah you
know but you know one of these days I
forget I'm done I know some people can't
take it but I don't really think it
hurts kids I didn't find it I mean I
didn't yeah like I said I sat there for
11 hours and it shouldn't it's it's just
like a mild sunburn yeah oh my god I
felt when she's scabbing and weird
yes works afterward yeah yeah pieces of
this one fell off yeah they always do
during that period just you know yeah
it's just like it's supposed to that's
what suppose that yeah you just have
random guys have guns with or sometimes
homemade tattoo guns yeah
damn motor out of a damn Walkman mm-hmm
piece of plastic on the end of a needle
going through a pin and you can just put
batteries on it and you can you can
tattoo with that yeah and they weren't
add to it with that yeah that's true
yeah so that's the story behind the
tattoos for you for the person on
YouTube that asked everybody else also I
had a couple of shout outs we have a new
patron named James so hey there how are
you doing thank you very good
thanks man $25 park patron and also our
friend of the show melanie has sent us
another paypal donations yes paypal
energy very much once a month sometimes
yeah than that so that's like super
awesome yeah
and yeah so we really do appreciate that
you know like a check out our patreon
Jamie's new books gonna be ready soon
yeah I'm working on the index yeah I
still have a couple of chapters to
record but not that many I think it's
only like five chapters left your record
and edit but the writing of it is done
the formatting is almost all done except
for the index like I said I'm working on
the index and I just have to do like I
have to find a good image for the cover
if you like part 1 part 1 and part 2
you'll love this too this is every bit
as good if not better huh I feel like
they're getting better as yeah yeah I
hope I hope they are or to the cases
because it's more modern times too so
you got more to talk about yeah that's
true yeah although it's weird because I
feel like the second one was probably
the longest just because you know 60s
and 70s that was a big serial killer era
there were like a lot of them running
around now that you get into like the
80s and 90s there's still a really lot
there's some serial killers there's a
lot of weird murders and stuff but I
feel like probably most of them have
been solved like a lot of more of them
have been solved so there aren't as many
that are unsolved although a lot like
unidentified there's like I put it like
a lot of unidentified but I couldn't
like there was like a million more than
that but I couldn't grow them all in
there so alright so speaking of murders
yeah let's get into talking about Bob
bird Ella like I said also known as the
Kansas City butcher or the collector for
reasons which I will explain later
not taking he from Kansas City Kansas
City Missouri Missouri although he
wasn't born there though he was actually
born in Ohio someplace like Koya hoga
Falls or somewhere yeah coin Falls Ohio
so he was actually born there but they
he moved to Kansas City later on okay so
how you gonna do this so I'm just gonna
wing it like I always do alright you
know this is not a professional show
polish highly professional well
researchers yeah well you know
adequately research let's put it that
way
time you have in the amount of time that
I have all right
so Bob Rotella is thought to have
kidnapped tortured raped and murdered at
least six men between 1984 and 1987 they
think maybe more although he said that
that's all there was
and boy did he give a really graphic
description of all the [ __ ] that he did
to them later on like after they caught
him so special and some of them he kept
in captivity for more than a month Sam
yeah doing all kind of horrible things
okay all right so let's start at the
beginning this the guy what just the guy
with the dishwashing fluid dishwashing
for put in people's eyes yes is it that
guy not dishwasher include it was like
other [ __ ] it was like alcohol and like
drain cleaner yeah that guy just kind of
came to me once she said that he kept
someone for a month I was going yeah I
think I know you tomba kept me tied up
to a bit yeah yeah yep that's him yeah I
know this guy yeah he's playing he was
this this guy here was taking advantage
of junkies yeah are like homeless male
prostitute type yes male prostitutes you
know people who like Street kids here
problems its up sadistic homosexual
predator yeah do is suck at that yeah
you want to follow him this guy's
clutches he took pictures of it why he
was doing it too yeah and I hate to say
but if you go on murder pedia which is
really good website this it didn't just
have serial killers it just has anybody
that ever murdered anybody
yeah and this had a photo gallery and I
was looking for it for photos for the
show and it has photos of some of the
photos that he took I don't know if the
people in there dead or not some of them
aren't some are some of them are and
some weren't um so if you want to go
look at those you may I'm not gonna put
them in the show the only one I'm
putting in the show is the one of the
kid that's arrived yeah because at least
I know that he's still I remember one of
the photographs I saw he'd actually put
needles in a dude's eyes and that sounds
like something
yeah he just like took he had like over
300 like polarizing like this [ __ ] so
yeah so let's go back to the origin
story of this [ __ ] sadistic
[ __ ] yeah as I said he was born
in Cuyahoga Falls Ohio now his dad who
had the same name as him he was the
senior his dad was he worked for the
Ford Motor Company was a dye sitter back
when that was like a thing that you
could do um his mom was a housewife as
many moms were back then they were
actually raised Catholic as an Italian
Catholic family very religious household
apparently very strict so there's one of
your problems right there some Penta
energies yeah
man you know we don't know the details
though you know yeah yeah um he also had
a younger brother so when he was a kid
um bopper della he seemed very very
smart from the outset but um it wasn't
real social he always like kind of kept
to himself he did like be you know very
solitary kind of hobbies he didn't like
to play outside he wasn't very athletic
he had some health problems he had like
really high blood pressure like so high
that they had to put him on medication
this was like from when he was a little
kid he was real real real nearsighted so
he had to like this big ass like coke
bottle glasses um you know so obviously
that meant that he got bullied by a
bunch of other kids um so since he
didn't really like go out and he wasn't
real sporty or anything um his dad
thought that he was like a failure
because you know Roberts younger brother
was like super into sports and was like
really athletic and stuff and the dad
thought that that was what a boy should
be so he would always like kind of [ __ ]
on Roberts like why aren't you more like
your younger brother like he's way more
awesome than you and all this other kind
of stuff so there's your second problem
right there
also the dad was supposedly emotionally
and physically abusive I mean the thing
is they they say things like oh you know
he beat the
with a leather strap and stuff like that
nowadays that would be abusive back then
you know not so much like I feel like
most people kind of got that corporal
punishment yeah during that time period
yeah so you know that's kind of yeah
that didn't create serial killers no
because like a lot of kids that grew up
in that era had that happen you know
what I mean that they would you know at
least get spanked or hit with a brush or
something like that yeah um so Bob goes
to school and as I said he does like
actually really really well but um you
know he gets picked on a lot by other
kids and he was kind of like um aloof
like you know which is very very distant
but his teachers like liked him and
thought he was like a good student now
right about the time he's you know a
tween or something like that he realizes
that he is gay now because of his family
upbringing and stuff like that he
thought he you know and plus it's you
know the 1950s new Canada uh yeah you
got to keep that [ __ ] to yourself so he
didn't really tell anyone until later I
believe until the late sixties early
seventies he supposedly had like a
girlfriend or two like in that time
period not a lot known about that now
when he gets into when he's about 15 16
years old he supposedly comes into this
kind of like like really getting into
like self-confident type of thing but in
a way that made him come across as like
an arrogant condescending douche you
know what I mean he seemed like one of
those guys that was like he was like
super smart like according doll his
teachers and stuff like that they
thought he was like really intelligent
in a really good student but he was one
of those guys that thought that he was
better than everybody else and smarter
than everyone else and so he was just
like had this sort of attitude a little
bit like Asperger's it might be um you
know yeah he definitely had something
like that he was especially
condescending toward women they said but
pretty much everybody you know a lot of
people couldn't really stand to be
around him just because he was just one
of those kind of like
well actually a type of yeah you know
what I mean you know you know what we
know oh yeah now right around this time
too he also started getting interested
in cooking he actually got really good
at that he was self-taught he got
interested in art and he started doing
like he painted like he was a fairly
good artist
he started corresponding with pen pals
mostly in like parts of Asia like the
Burma Vietnam stuff like that and he
collected stamps and coins and so he
would like trade like stamps like they
would send sent him stamps and like
pictures of stuff and so he kind of got
really interested in you know it's kind
of like quote-unquote primitive you know
art and artifacts and all that other
kind of [ __ ] so he started collecting
that kind of stuff too so then when he's
still in his teenage years this was
Christmas of 1965 his family goes to
visit like relatives or something for
Christmas or whatever and his dad drops
dead of a heart attack at 39 years old
now I guess that Robert had kind of a
complicated relationship with his dad
because it seems like I don't know it
seemed like he didn't like him and
everything but this seemed to be like
kind of a formative thing that happened
to him when he was a kid
cuz it happened like right around the
time that he was a teenager right around
the time that he was starting to develop
this new like you know douchey
self-confidence thing that he was doing
he tried to get back into Catholicism
you know after his dad died like I guess
to make himself feel better but found
that he didn't really that it didn't
really do the trick so then he started
like reading about other religions and
then later kind of went on to you know
kind of become not disinterested in
religion but like rejecting them you
know what I don't work well that's true
yeah so it seems like there was a lot of
things happening in this guy's teenage
years that sort of were baby not good
like happen and all take
another thing that happened to him are
right around the same time in 1965 was
he saw this movie called the collector
and as I said this is one of the reasons
why they called him this later on now
this was based on a novel by John Fowles
and it's actually about I've seen parts
of the movie actually it's very good the
movie was directed by William Wyler and
it's about a man who stalks and kidnaps
a woman that he thinks is pretty and he
takes her down in his stone basement
that doesn't have any windows and he
just tries to keep her captive like he's
not trying to kill her he's trying to
keep her alive like as a slave you know
what I mean it's like he's collecting
her that's the same book that Charlie
Leonard Blake wasn't doing yes yeah so
thanks a lot John Fowles you really you
inspired at least two serial killers but
I won't up I can't say anything because
it's like I write horror [ __ ] all the
time it's some serial killer like took
separate X something I wrote like I'd be
really you yeah yeah if you blame me
it's like it's just a story I just made
it up but yeah so apparently like in the
book like the woman he's trying to keep
this woman alive because he just wants
to keep like a you know he wants to keep
her like a butterfly in a jar or
something like that but she ends up
getting a disease and she dies and so
spoiler alert um but so Robert Byrd Ella
said that this book in this movie had
like a huge huge effect on him I need to
read this book because apparently it's
so good that it like trying to you won't
say real killers you keep a pretty woman
captive down in the basement she's gonna
be pretty for long well no I don't like
this guy's thinking I don't they're not
thinking I think they're they're it's
all like just this weird yeah fantasy
that they have in their heads it has no
basis in reality whatsoever yeah it's
like you know it's not about the woman's
about them of course it's all about them
of course it is they don't see that as a
person they just see that it's like it's
like the doll you know it's like a toy
yeah and [ __ ] even Robert Byrd Ella even
call
his victims that play toys later on so
that's how they see them they just see
them as objects yeah so okay so after um
burn Ella's dad died his mom remarried
as they usually did quickly back then
because you know a lot of women didn't
work and they're like well I don't want
to starve to death and I have two kids
so you know gotta marry the first dude
that comes along now there's there's a
there's this stereotype that women
didn't work that's actually [ __ ] no
I know you work yeah my grandma may
always worked my mama was yeah it was
just after World War two they were
encouraging women not to work yeah to be
well I feel like a lot of people's
everybody's coming back today or they
were all coming back from a war so they
just wanted to be housewife I mean maybe
middle upper middle class women didn't
have to work but they didn't work out
that way but most Muslims most people in
my economics this would have had to
because you wouldn't been able to get by
especially bad kid it was back in the
1800's when they mostly didn't work yeah
but I think about a ton of twenties
rolled around they were working most of
them I would I would I think so I'd have
to go back through my rolodex of
historical knowledge in my head I think
by the time that if I remember correctly
around the 20s around that time most of
them were working yeah I mean it would
be surprising if they didn't try I said
it's like part-time stuff but they were
working you know most of them yeah um
yeah so so she remarries and burn Ella
this pisses him off very much he does
not like his stepfather he and he
resents his mother for replacing his
father you know that whole thing so he
just kind of like withdraws back into
himself and you know all into his
collections and his antiques and
everything like that now starting from
about 1965 he started to and I'm not
really sure where he was getting the
money from but um he starts like
collecting like I said stamps coin coins
like all kind of art you know just
various little artifacts from like all
around the world and stuff and he had
actually built up such a big collection
that you know
fifteen 20 years later he was actually a
actually able to open a fairly
successful shop with all the stuff that
he had so he graduates from high school
in 1967 and he had gotten really good
grades like even his teachers had you
know encouraged him to go into like
independent study and all this other
kind of stuff so he was so supposedly
something genius um then he moved to
Kansas City because like I said he'd
been in Ohio before and he actually
wanted to go to college he enrolled at
the Kansas City Art Institute he wanted
to be a professor like I guess an art
teacher or some kind of anthropology
type of thing that he wanted to do and
the first year he was there he seemed to
do really well like all this professors
thought he was you know really smart and
he was really going places but then it
seemed like the second year he kind of
said [ __ ] it he started drinking a great
deal he started taking a lot of drugs he
started dealing drugs like he kind of
fell in with all the cats so he became
kind of a minor drug dealer he started
getting to the point where he's just
like you know [ __ ] all y'all you can't
tell me what to do you don't know me
blah blah blah so he eventually ended up
dropping out now one of the reasons that
he dropped out was because one of his
quote unquote art projects was he took a
duck and a chicken like alive and he
tortured them and killed them
and cooked them and that was like a
quote unquote art project and his
teachers were like no so he was gonna
get in trouble for that so he tortured
them where I'm not I'm not really sure
how he tortured them at home or at
school and fun everybody in front of
everybody oh okay they stopped him and
they stopped him from doing it and they
were just like I don't know if they
kicked him out but he you know left at
some point now when he was oh he also um
took a dog and gave it like
tranquilizers and stuff like that like
as an experiment right type of [ __ ]
tries to knock the dog yeah he's doing
this kind of
right so when he's 19 years old he gets
arrested for trying to sell meth to an
undercover cop
he posts the $3,000 bond which is more
than 20 grand in like today money so I
guess he had some money um and he pled
guilty you've got a five-year suspended
sentence now a month later him and a
couple of other friends of his get
arrested again for possession of LSD and
marijuana this time he didn't have the
money to bond out so he actually spent
five days in jail but then you know they
didn't have enough evidence to hold him
or whatever so they ended up just
letting him go now it should be noted
though that a lot of this money has been
like for these drug arrests and stuff
that's gonna like accrue and you know it
was one of the things later on that he
why he started taking in boarders at his
house and stuff like that so yeah so he
quit school and then he moves to this
house the famous address in Kansas City
were all of his horrible things would
happen for a 3 1 5 Charlotte Street it's
kind of this 2 or 3 it looks like a
three-story house it's gone now the guy
that bought it after this jackhole died
tore it down and sold the lot sold the
land but yeah so that but there's
pictures of it but this is where he was
doing all his crap so he had brunella
had kind of come out at this point since
he was in art school and everything and
he starts hanging out with you know I
guess what they would call in the UK
your Rough Trade
you know he's male prostitutes you know
Runaways drug addicts street kids stuff
like that he seemed to have a few
friends his own age but because he was a
little bit older by this point but you
know as the years went on like all of
his you know peers like all the people
the same age as him kind of like ya know
they thought it was a little weird or
anything so you know so he ends up just
hanging out with these kids pretty much
I mean like teenagers and like early
twenties now it's weird too because
all during the 70's and 80's Rodela
was like his neighbors like they thought
he was a little weird and they thought
he was a little you know quote-unquote
flamboyant but nobody ever thought that
he was up to anything like nefarious
because he was supposedly he was like
the chairman of like their [ __ ]
neighborhood watch [ __ ] and like he did
all this like civic minded kind of stuff
and so everybody thought that he was
like an okay guy no I made her yeah it
was it was kind of that kind of
situation in fact the two have a lot in
common
cuz Rader was kind of like that too with
his kind of like superior robots don't
aim for don't for one second say that I
have everything in common with this
why not am i hurting your feelings well
he's gay yeah you know I'm attracted to
women as God intended you know okay
Danice man it is yeah I did it that was
another youtube comment that somebody
made this and they were watching the you
know the trial the BTK trial and
everything and they're like instead
about to like talk like I just
remembered him yeah and I pictured him
in my head and that voice came out yeah
yeah a channel did that's what I mean
and that is what he sounds like
no just you know several problem some
men have sexual problems and they have
to find ways to alleviate the pressure
might ever try somebody up you know you
know they might get upset yeah take it
upset I told her you know I was gonna
have to kill her she got a little upset
of course you know but Aaron I swear to
God like when we're doing the show about
that Duchenne like we're I was watching
like the [ __ ] [ __ ] of him saying all
that said every time he said that the
victim got upset it was like oh my god
if I could reach through
[ __ ] I had a time machine and I could
go back and just punch you right in the
[ __ ] taint every time you said that I
would goddamn it
yeah you know they'd pick it up set yeah
imagine that
that's Annette yeah [ __ ] it's
understandable but it's okay still gotta
do it you know yeah yeah yeah what are
you gonna do yeah so so this [ __ ] um
his whole thing and I don't buy this for
a second but his whole thing was like oh
all during the 76 boy oh well I wasn't
having sex with them then he's like what
I was trying to do was I was trying to
help them because a lot of them were
drug addicts or straight kids or
prostitutes or so so I was trying to
like get them out of it so you just try
to help yeah and the same trend I don't
believe that
well it's weird because like okay I feel
like his whole thing - and this is
another thing that [ __ ] BTK did as
well his whole thing is just like you
know pushing responsibility off onto
someone else yeah so I think that his
whole thing about like why I started
killing these victims is because they
didn't appreciate what I was doing or
they didn't recognize what I was doing
for them so it's their fault yeah I kind
of feel like he had help yeah yeah I
kind of feel like he had some of that
kind of [ __ ] going on and that he said
something kind of kind of like that like
during all those confessions and stuff
that they didn't appreciate like what he
was doing or they didn't like know why
what was really going on is that it was
a bunch of pretty much streetwise
grizzly little junkie kids you know they
know that they have this pervs keeping
out on them trying to give them gifts to
try to you know yeah you would let him
like live in his house yeah Bret free
money stuff they knew he was trying to
get up in that booty yeah you know so
they'd appreciate it you know so it's
their fault so I had to kill him because
they weren't appreciate they run
integrate sky and he's appreciate me
trying to get up in his booty you know
that's that's that was the thinking have
you seen this [ __ ] though it's
like I don't want him anywhere yeah yeah
don't care from the girl or guys my god
within [ __ ] 5,000 miles of mine I've
seen him but I forgot what he look like
he wasn't bad looking when he was really
young
but when he got busted yeah he wasn't
looking too good
yeah so he's helping with ulterior
motives of course you know I mean yeah
well clear yeah he's working like dumb
kids yeah they were like you know they'd
been on lived on the street and [ __ ]
like that
it wasn't a the score it wasn't true
love so I had to kill him I guess but
yeah they wanna punish them yeah I
there's definitely an aspect of that
it's like what the [ __ ] is the matter
with these dudes man I don't know
but yeah so while he's at this place as
I said you know he still had all this
debt accrued from like all these arrests
and stuff that he still had to pay so he
started working as a short-order cook in
like a bunch of different restaurants
and he was actually really good at it
like he's and he actually worked his way
up through the ranks it's like even he
even got to like head chef at a couple
restaurants and he even like at one
place he even started like a training
program for like the younger chefs so
like I said he's doing like all this
civic minded kind of stuff so everyone
thought he was like a super cool guy and
all helpful and everything and then it's
just a way if I can get in your hands
around somebody else yeah and to get a
notoriety and appreciation they always
want like you know positively accolades
yeah
they want their greatness to be
recognized and I feel like another thing
that this dude had too which was another
thing and I didn't even realize until we
started talking about BTK how much how
similar these two guys are is that this
guy I mean he's from [ __ ] Ohio right
no slag against Ohio but it's a hiya you
know and then he moves to Kansas City
Missouri and he's like super into like
he styles himself as this really
intelligent worldly type of person it's
like oh he's into all this all this all
this art like exotic artifacts and
everything like that but he never went
anywhere like he never traveled he never
did anything like that and I feel like
that
maybe came across as like he felt like
he was a failure or he was like a fake
you know what I mean because it's like
he's just like this small-town schlub
right that has these aspirations of
being like this
you know worldly kind of suave yeah
world traveling like art collector type
of dude and he like never like I said he
was just like he was local yeah he
worked in restaurants in Kansas City and
that's like that's all he did
go to Europe yeah I feel like Heath he
thought that that was what he deserved
or he thought that that was worth like
that's just the employee image the image
yeah yeah so as I said so he's like
working as a cook and stuff and he's
actually like you know making okay money
doing that he also started a side
business like selling a lot of these
like antiques and artifacts and stuff
that he had collected over the years and
it actually ended up being like fairly
successful he just kind of operated it
out of his house at first and then he
was like working as a cook also and he
would also you know because the house
was not a huge house that he had but it
was like three stories and I had some
extra rooms so sometimes he would rent
rooms out like yeah you know yeah he
would let these kids stay there
sometimes rent-free but some of the
people that live there like actually
didn't pay rent and stuff too so he made
extra money that way also now eventually
this side business with with the
artifact selling and antiques and
everything got so successful that he was
able to quit working as a chef and just
do that full-time now later he opened up
his own store now store is a little bit
of a misnomer it wasn't a store store
like a whole storefront it was actually
like a booth at the Westport flea market
which I'm I think it's still there as
far as I knew but it was like it was um
like a permanent I guess it looked like
a permanent like a shop like just at
this flea market cuz like it had like a
little neon sign and all this other kind
of [ __ ] okay so yeah well the shop at a
flea market yeah like a shop at a flea
market but it's like I don't think it
was like super huge or anything like
that
now his the name of the store
was famously Bob's bizarre PA Z aar
bizarre be i za r re okay cuz how funny
is that
so it's bizarre yeah well that's kind of
his thing is that and i have like a
picture of the business card that he had
to but he was like really into i think
the business card even says like
anthropological anthropological or
something like or exotic i don't but
what the [ __ ] word he was he used but
um he would sell you know like like
trinkets that they didn't really sell a
lot of back then i guess but it's like
he had like all these were like antiques
he had like shrunken heads like human
skulls that kind of [ __ ] you know what I
mean like dead bird skeleton trying to
sell curios yeah it's like it's like
that kind of thing yeah so even though
like the shop did okay um he still
wasn't making like quite enough to live
on again so that was why he kept getting
like all these lodgers and stuff like
that so he was seems like he was trying
to you know just barely getting by with
that but he wasn't working as a cook
anymore now while he was working at this
store he makes friends with this other
guy who has a booth at the market whose
name is Paul Howell now so his that
guy's booth was like next to his now
Paul hat Powell had a son named Jerry
now at first Jerry and his buddies used
to always make fun of Bob Rotella
like making fun of how gay he was and I
guess I'm like pickin on him and stuff
but according to Bob Byrd Ella uh Jerry
would do that like goofy and all this
other kind of [ __ ]
but then he admitted it's like oh yeah
me and my friends like we make drug
money by being male prostitutes so you
know it's I I don't know if that's true
but that that sounds about right
right no I'm saying that's what like all
these dudes that are kind of just like
although you too gay to again and it's
like turns out they're [ __ ] doing the
same kind of [ __ ] cuz it's a it's a
self-loathing thing you gotta he made
that up
yeah it could go either way I'm just
it wouldn't shock me if that was true so
so he's like you know friends with this
Jerry Howell kid now Paul Howell who was
the guy who was the kid's dad he later
moved his business out of the flea
market and then he went to this other
store later on now apparently there's
like a year or two in there where Bob
Rotella and Jerry kind of lost contact
but then they kind of like befriended
each other once again and bird Ella like
supposedly like gave him legal advice
and [ __ ] like that because I guess Jerry
Howell was like you know getting into
trouble like he did when you're a
teenage boy so in 1984
Jerry was 19 years old and would become
Bob bird Ella's first victim where are
we on time we're at 44 minutes do you
want to take a break all right yeah all
right so we are going to take a break
right now when we come back we're going
to talk about Bob bird ellas murders
since we just I just thought that was a
good place to stop because now we're
starting to get into like all the
horrible murder [ __ ] so okay we're gonna
take a break we will be back in just a
few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but if you got to say baby cookie
nothing okay that's your little spot
isn't it when mommy and daddy do the
show that's your wool spot she's right
behind Mama's laptop and then there's
the camera and she's right there she's
not pushing it at the moment
[Applause]
oh my goodness this is a new mint cat
toy that I got for them they're really
into it in my write Beijing did super
minty and fun yeah I know she's like why
are you filming me stop filming me
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back now before the
break we were getting right into the
part where Robert Byrd Ellis started
killing people
yeah we're getting to the good part at
least as far as they know yeah so as I
said as far as they know his first
victim was 19 year old Jerry Howell who
was the son of the guy that had owned
the booth next to him at the flea market
yeah so apparently what he did to this
poor kid he said that he was going to
take him to the city of Merriam for a
dance contest and instead he kidnapped
him gave him a bunch of alcohol valium
and some other drugs until he was
unconscious then then injected him with
tranquilizer when he was completely out
he tied him to the bed in his house
where he was held captive for 28 hours
repeatedly drugged tortured and raped
with also foreign objects inserted into
orifices you don't necessarily want
foreign objects inserted into unless
you're into that okay so yeah so all
this shit's going on apparently
according to Byrd Ella in his later
statement you know he was saying
obviously Jerry was you know begging
foremen asking him why he was doing this
because he was he had known him for
quite a long time and he thought they
were friends so he didn't really
understand why this was happening and
then Rodela said well then I figured he
was probably going to die from having
the gag on and all the drugs and
everything and after the after he died
or he went unconscious wanted to a coma
or whatever he tried to do CPR on him or
so he said but it didn't work and he
ended up dying anyway as I said after 28
hours so I guess after he couldn't
revive him what was the actual cause of
death did they
can you say I'm actually not really sure
might it could have been any number of
things yeah I never recover the body or
anything most of the bodies were not
found okay
and I do not think that his really it's
all on his story well they did find a
skull and a severed head on his property
Beckett not of this kid but of two other
victims what I'm saying is is that
there's no there's no remains behind so
we really won't know how the kid died or
what happened yeah it's just kind of
like it's just what he said that's what
he says okay so he says that after Gerry
Howell died cuz it made that a lot worse
than that
yeah probably was yeah I mean this was
his first one and they do get a lot
worse later on so maybe he was still
trying [ __ ] out looks like a horrible
thing to say so he apparently takes the
kids body drags it down to the basement
he hangs the body up from the ceiling
over a big pot and then he made like a
whole bunch of cuts like um to his
jugular vein his like inner like the
inside of his arm like right here and
stuff and drained all the blood out then
he took a chainsaw in a boning knife and
cut the body up into pieces put those
pieces in a garbage bag put that garbage
bag in another garbage bag and left it
out on the curb for the garbage man
so the reason they think that they
didn't find most of the bodies was that
they were in the landfill right because
he said that that's how he got rid of
most of the bodies will be put him out
for a garbage collection so funny when
these city boys decide to dismember a
body using a damn chainsaw it seems very
messy yeah anybody who's ever dressed a
deer or does anything just a very sharp
three-inch pocketknife will just reduce
a human sized animal down to just night
nice package little pieces of meat and
whatever and there's no blood very
rarely
yeah yeah no they just uh you know it
doesn't even get anywhere I guess this
guy they just I'm out there doing you
know I mean damn I mean no field skills
he did clean the [ __ ] up later on but
it's like when the cops came in later
and like did the luminol all around all
over the place long as you field dress
and get those internal organs out of
there and into a bag it's that's with
deer protein pretty sick organs out it
comes right out you know you can just
look up you can look up all cousin
concept in you know tutorials a lot of
field dress a deer a human is exactly
that same way it's the same layout you
know all animals are you know well since
we're all like we're all lazy yeah so
it's all just like that as soon as those
internal organs are out there's knit
that's not a messy process yeah
chainsaw would just splatter that [ __ ]
around everywhere I don't know why you
can do it maybe he's just into the chain
just she just didn't know or that's what
he got me there no any better you can
have a little 3-inch pocketknife or
remove something to remove human leg
right at the joint off just cleanly and
not spill any blood you know just dumb
well and he's a good he's real killer
he's a cook yeah he's supposed to have
knife experiences and dealing with meat
and stuff it's the same thing just eat
there's some kind of fetish that's what
I was thinking it's like because you
think he would know better especially
when he's doing this [ __ ] in this house
yeah and like I said a chainsaw just
seems very messy it seemed yeah it seems
like it maybe he just I don't know maybe
he just like chainsaw this is just like
a thing that he had I mean you know
anytime you're dealing with meats or
fish or anything you know in the kitchen
you get a whole fish and you can gut it
and fillet it down to nothing you know
it's not really a big difference if you
have the skills to do that you can do
that to the human cadaver yeah it's not
gonna be any different than a deer the
shapes can be and really a deer a deer
is the same thing that you would do to a
rabbit it's a lot smaller and that's
basically the same thing as a chicken or
pig pig just bigger version of the
chicken in a rabbit yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah we all have the same layout so as
it turned out because Bob bordello was
known to be acquainted with Jerry Howell
and they were known to be friends he
actually was questioned in Jerry Howells
disappearance but he said oh well I
drove him to that dance contest over in
Marion but it's like that's the last
time I saw can't help you there officer
yeah and they bought it so you know now
something else that Bob bird Ella did
and I guess he started doing this with
his very first murder was he kept very
very detailed journals about what he did
to all of his victims he seemed very
like I said it seemed like experiments
like he was like super into like trying
things out and he had like all these
little codes and stuff that he would
write in there like all the stuff that
he didn't like what they did and how
they reacted and it's all this like I've
read like little pieces of it and it's
like it's super super creepy because
he's just like so detached it I'm saying
it's just like talking about a bug yeah
he just says stuff like you know like
when he was like if he's restraining
somebody he'd put like restrained no
struggle you know what I mean like he
would put things like that right and
then he had like like I said he had all
this I'll get into a little bit later
but like all these little codes he had
about all these little things that he
did like to the bodies and to the
victims and it's just like that it's
just like horrifying so when they caught
him later
he said I thought this was like a weird
thing room to say but he said oh well I
wasn't doing it for enjoyment okay I was
doing it for quote unquote physical and
mental satisfaction that's the same day
which I was gonna yeah I was like how is
that different yeah I mean he's just
trying to analyze it by greater what
course you know that's what I mean I
have sexual problems yeah that's my
babies just like that it's just like
that like he sees he sees himself as
better and he sees himself is like I'm
going to experiment on this
oh this is this interesting thing that
I'm doing it's like I wonder what would
happen if I did this and I wonder what
happened but he doesn't see that as he
doesn't see them as a person and he just
like sees them as a thing like I said
it's almost like it's like somebody
pulling wings off flies yeah and then
they do all this weird [ __ ] they don't
really want to talk about it or
rationalize that I trader never really
did far as I know I don't think he
really be any comments or why he's
dressing up women's clothes and clothing
and getting down into graves yeah we
picture of you know yes he did do that
you know did he ever say that why he did
that I don't know about it in here any
explanation maybe he did but I don't
know it cuz that almost seems like
something that he would have been
embarrassed pricey some along the lines
of well you know sometimes when a man
has sexual problems he's trying to
communicate certain things to law
enforcement yeah it'd be like that
either
he's gonna be good at this he's gonna
he's gonna he's gonna he's gonna he's
not gonna say you know well you know I
have to decide dress up like women yeah
he's not gonna say that yeah he doesn't
say oh it gives me a boner
you didn't say that yeah he's not even
though that's true who's gonna say some
what I was it was art performance art
I'm trying to I was trying to put myself
into the place of the victim yeah yeah
trying to show the investigators how I
saw you know the victims you know that's
probably exactly yeah I wanted them to
see what I saw
yeah it's gonna be something like that
like but that's not what the deal was
well no the deal was his dead he liked
to dress up in women's clothes and put a
damn mask on his face
yeah ask and it's like what just admit
it he wanted to be a woman just a minute
he what is he wanted to be the if they
can't admit it that's why they have
problems he wanted to be he wanted to be
the perpetrator and the victim at the
same time yeah that's what it was
yeah the whole you mind the whole
experience I think I heard someone say
that they want it we never killing the
victim they also kind of wanted to
experience what the victim was they
wanted to be the victim
at the same time they couldn't do it
yeah I guess I cannot good it's not just
sad ISM and it's not masochism zits
sadomasochism they want both ends yeah
but but you know I guess that makes them
yeah they want they want both aspects of
it like I said that all yeah you know
that's what I think Rader was doing I
think you probably got it there it was
sadomasochism he wanted to be the killer
and the victim yeah yeah that makes
sense
so okay so his next known victim this
happened in April of 1985 now this guy
who was 23 years old his name was Robert
Sheldon now he had apparently been a
tenant in the house before um a long
time ago and like he paid rent and
everything like that but then he had
moved away but then later he came back
like in April of 85 and he said you know
can I just stay in your house again for
a little while so according to bird Ella
he said well you know even though this
guy had been a good tenant like he
always paid his rent on time and
everything like that he saw him as
quote-unquote an inconvenience so he
decided that he was going to collect him
or you know take him prisoner
so on April 12th um he comes home from
work and Robert Sheldon is apparently in
the house and he's kind of a little
drunk so um so Robert is like okay well
I'm gonna take care of this now he later
told the police he said I was not
sexually attracted to Robert Sheldon I
just thought he was essentially a pain
in my ass and so I just thought that I
was going to you know do it and slave
him I guess cuz like I said he didn't
just he didn't kill people outright he
kept them for a long time yeah and did
various [ __ ] I think he is - I think
he is - so it's gotta be some kind of
powerful force driving him to do this
yeah to me to me I'm thinking lust yeah
well it does seem nice
desire it does seem like he's like and a
power trip it's a powerchair balls yeah
he's basically fleece Johnson booty
warrior go the coupon you go not at work
you to go search for a fleece Johnson
booty warriors can't tell you now I'm
gonna have to go look that up booty
warrior booty
I'm gonna have to me I'm you know well
I'm gonna make a booty warrior shirt and
I'm gonna make you wear it got all these
men locked up and somebody gonna have to
give up that booty yeah that's what he
said yeah you know but he knows what he
is he's a lawyer he's gonna take it take
your booty that's what's going on
yeah I hate you know it in a horrible
horrible yeah I hate I hate you know
shatter people's images of themselves
and he's trying to say well you don't
gay but I wasn't attracted to these men
Danny well some of them he said he was
but this one he said he was he's
[ __ ] I know I think you he's
[ __ ] he's just what it is maybe that
guy wasn't attractive enough normally
he'd be attracted to him so he didn't
want to admit it yeah that he was kind
of lowering himself maybe he thought the
guy was a skank or so because I really
like that one but yeah but how I bet how
much I bet he had sex with that dude oh
yeah I think he did so there you go I
think he had sex with all of them were
you raped all of them yeah I don't want
to say he had sex with them because it
was so there you go I mean that's the
motive yeah I'm just saying that later
he said that it's like I just thought
this guy was a pain in the ass like
staying in the house and it's like I
just had a lot of anger and frustration
built up and I wanted to take it out on
someone and he happened to be there so I
figure isn't it I'm gonna get him out of
the house like you're really shooting
yourself in the ass story he's telling
the authorities they yeah they really do
have like in a little imaginative like
fantasy life yeah
he's blaming the victims and then he
yeah he's blaming the victims and then
he tells this story this is how he's
just giving this is how he's
seeing himself into this role yeah you
know I mean in the eyes of the police oh
it didn't happen didn't happen because
I've been you know fantasizing about it
for years then finally took the plunge
no they did this to me yeah all right I
said it happens slowly and then one
thing hey you know it could happen to
anybody
that's that's what they that's the story
he's trying to tell she asked me this
maybe that makes them feel better I feel
bad that they think anyone would do the
same thing yes he's trying to talk the
cops into believing that this is how
that even though everybody can see what
you understand Jana
Hey don't you guys feel the same way now
that I put everyone like right now
trying to rationalize it to the cops
yeah I guess now but yeah so so he takes
Robert Sheldon takes a bunch of
sedatives again and like drugs him ties
into the bed holds him captive for three
days um he was one of the I think as far
as I know he was the first one that he
started doing like the really horrible
like you know not that the other one
wasn't horrible but like the the more
famous like tortures on like he would
take like drain cleaner and he would
like swab it on his eyeballs um he took
his wrists and like bound them with
piano wire cuz he wanted to see if it
would like cause permanent nerve damage
like to his hands like you wouldn't be
able to use them he took like um a
caulking gun and like filled his ears up
with caulk like to see if he could cause
permanent hearing loss like [ __ ] like
that it's like how the [ __ ] do you even
think of that kind of looking [ __ ] dude
experimentations that's what I mean how
did said why does this stuff even occur
I'm a horror writer in the stuff that
occurred I thought he injected the drain
cleaner into the guy's eye sometimes he
did needle sometimes he did and and I
think I will blind you I mean well none
of these dudes live though so yeah
except the last guy he got away yeah but
um yeah and he'd also like stick needles
and other fingernails on
yeah so apparently Robert Sheldon had
been held captive for three days and
then on April 15th like this workman
shows up because he's gonna do some work
on the roof of barela's house so Robert
Burnell is like oh well workman's gonna
be here guess I better kill this guy
yeah so he just put a bag over his head
and suffocated him yeah then he took him
up to the third floor bathroom of the
house and cut him up yeah and as far as
I know put most of his body out with the
garbage but he did keep his head because
this guy's skull was one of the heads
that was found later on no was she
conscious when you killed him or is he
unconscious I'm not really sure because
he kept them drugged a lot and he kept a
very detailed log of that as well yeah
like all of the drugs that he enjoyed
like I injected three you know 30 CC's
of whatever this was like at this time
and then this what I remember most of
them are pretty and capacitated most of
the time yeah which maybe that's like
some small mercy I guess maybe they
didn't know what's happening to him most
of the time it's [ __ ] horrible so
okay so the next one this happened in
June now this guy was named Mark Wallace
now he kind of knew him a little bit but
he came across him and this is like so
random but apparently Mark Wallace I
guess he was like partially homeless
like a lot of the time he's just stayed
in hotels or slept in his car or
whatever and I guess it was a really bad
thunderstorm one night and Mark Wallace
kind of knew Bob Redell
like he was kind of known around the
neighborhood so he went and like hid out
in his toolshed like in his yard like to
get out of the rain and brunella found
him in there and was like hey why don't
you come inside the house it's nice and
warm in there and you know I'll give you
a food and all this other kind of [ __ ]
so he also said that he would give him
some chlorpromazine it's like Oh that'll
you know chill you out and everything
yeah and Mark's like yeah okay whatever
so he gives him it and of course it like
renders him unconscious so again he
takes his drug to victim up and
restrains them to the bed I think he was
in captivity for about a day he had
stuff like he would take like those
alligator clip things and like clamp him
on his nipples and shock that kind of
stuff he took hypodermic needles and put
him into the muscles on his back like to
see what would happen and Mark Wallace I
don't he didn't last much more than day
like he died from the drugs like the gag
was like cutting off his breathing like
he had lack of oxygen and stuff
they said that he noted this victims
time of death as 7 p.m. on June 23rd so
he wrote that down in his book time of
death just like he was a [ __ ] doctor
or something do you think crazy
he's a shitbird yeah he's dead now so
the next incident occurred on September
26 1985 which also happened to be my
13th birthday hmm so Bob bird Ella gets
a phone call from someone he knew named
James Farris and James Farris again like
you know they'd known each other like
around the scene or whatever and he's
like you know I need somewhere to stay
for a couple of days sober della said
fine now he specifically as soon as he
got that phone call he's like okay well
I'm gonna kidnap this no because
apparently some people stayed at the
house and didn't get it he just picked
particular ones because a lot of people
were stayed in and out of his house like
during this time period and not all of
them ended up getting killed but this
guy definitely did now according to Byrd
Ella
James Farris was the first and I don't
know why how he justifies this but he
says this was the first victim that I
just intentionally wanted to inflict all
this torture upon what was that other
[ __ ] you were doing I was just like oh I
just fell on him and electrocuted his
nipples with alligator play okay [ __ ]
it's like what are you talking about I
don't intend to torture this guy just
slowly happened but just when I intended
see yeah yeah yeah that's some weird
[ __ ] yeah I just accidentally like he's
lying poured caulk in his ear he's lying
to the cab
yeah and oh [ __ ]
damnit so this lick this make it's like
I find this deaf as day but it also
makes me really angry so so he meets
James Harris at a bar and then he brings
him back to the house and then he
smashes up a bunch of tranquilizers and
puts him in his food and then he ties
him to the bed now this guy lived about
27 hours there was also electrical
shocks he shocked him on the shoulder
shocked him on the testicles he would do
five minutes at a time shocking for five
doesn't let the electricity go through
there huh which would that do to your
testicles when they blow door no [ __ ]
man just [ __ ] lots of pain I mean
five minutes doesn't sound like a long
time unless you're being electrocuted
that's a very very long time yeah yikes
yeah dudes crazy uh yes so again he did
the whole needle thing sticking them in
the guy's neck back and his genitals
yeah um so apparently at understandably
the victim is kind of getting like
delirious and out of it and bird Ella is
you know keeping up the torture he's
also raping the guy which he did to the
other ones as well I thought that went
without saying until he writes in his
little book that Ferris is unable to sit
up more than 10 to 15 seconds which duh
yeah right and then his next entry says
very delayed breathing and then they
said this kind of this is a little
upsetting but he said the next thing
that he said was I guess the guy died
because he said he was 86th that was
what he said for you know yeah which
that's kind of a chef's term but I think
that's kind of like gone out into the
wider like I know what it meant even
though I never worked in a kitchen so
yeah so that was like his code for like
stopping the project yeah because that's
what he called them a project that's
nice yes so they said it Raider yeah
it's a project you know well that's what
I mean it's like it's it's a
dehumanizing yeah it's like an object
that's all there isn't
and that's how they see it and I just
that like blows my [ __ ] mind that
somebody can see another person like
that you know I mean like intellectually
I get it but I don't I don't know I
don't understand I can't understand
doing that to basically the innocent
innocent person that's what I mean it's
like it's another thing like if you
caught this guy if you caught Bob or
della it's like yeah I could do it to
that guy yeah I would still think he was
a person hasn't be a reason yeah but
like he's got a guy like I said monster
that you thought you've done this kind
of [ __ ] you kind of renounced your
personhood I think at that point once
you've gone past that limitation yes
these kind of dudes when you talk about
him you know you say well I don't know
how somebody can do that to another
person I'm like oh I can cuz I do that
to that dude yeah if I got a whole day I
do yeah [ __ ] you but you wouldn't do it
to like an innocent understand they
they're into that kind of false power
trip yeah and talking about person like
they're not a person yeah yeah you know
what I mean it's just that's not power
well honestly even even a weakling can
do that to another person if you get an
advantage over and most of them are yeah
so it's not power you know yeah well
they don't really see that Holly yeah
they don't seem to understand that so
the next victim was a guy named Todd
Stoops now he was married he actually
had a wife but he was a drug addict and
also worked as a prostitute sometimes to
you know get money for his drug habit um
he had actually lived in bird Ellis
house before like I said cuz he'd had
lodgers off and on and he had Todd had
lived there a couple of times and then
had moved out I think his wife lived
there too for a little while like the
second time but they had moved out like
sometime before but then they ran into
each other again
in June of 1986 now Todd at that time
needed some money for drugs he needed
specifically $13 which was today's about
thirty dollars in today's money so I
don't know what kind of jerk
but so he needed some drug money so Bob
helpful Oh Bob was like hey come back to
my house I'll give you some lunch we can
have sex I'll give you money for drugs
so Todd says okay now in this case bird
Ella did say that he was that he had
always been really attracted to this
particular guy so he apparently was
super happy to get his hands on him I
guess because it's like this was a guy
that he always thought was hot which
that's [ __ ] up
but yeah now Todd Stoops was actually in
captivity for two weeks and the torture
just got like worse and worse and worse
like the whole time and keep in mind too
that not only is he's doing this dude to
do the knows he know he knew all of them
yes weird [ __ ] error there were at least
acquaintances yeah but he liked this one
yeah yeah well like I said it was almost
like this is almost kind of like that
you know where it goes back to where he
was reading that book the collector it's
like he wanted he didn't care if he
liked he just wanted to possess it he
wanted to have it like I said like like
a dollar yeah it was like a Dahmer thing
where he went so what did you do to him
yes so he just went he said I'm gonna
turn this one into a sex slave there's
like incapacitated I can do whatever I
want to them whatever I want so he
wanted to keep him alive for a long time
so another thing he would do is like he
would have like the guy's eyes would be
closed and he would take like a spatula
and then like put the spatula on there
and like electrified the [ __ ] spatula
and like trying to keep trying to like
blind him and then he would take the
drain cleaner and he injected it into
his lair Nick's truck came from Tom to
try to keep him from talking or
screaming yeah or anything like that
did it work not that I know okay but
yeah burn your throat atropine
I would imagine yeah so yeah so this
poor guy and it's like you know he's
denying him food he's raping him all
this time now in June 27th this is real
special and just this is a little rough
so you know so he apparently took his
fist and he was fisting the guy so
stridently i guess is the word that he
ruptured the guy's anal wall so they're
just blood it's just everywhere that
didn't kill the guy immediately but it
contributed to his death later on so he
said like the the guy's health obviously
turned to deteriorate after that he
tried to give the guy food it's like he
just kept throwing everything up he
couldn't sit up anymore like or breathe
and he actually ended up dying on July
1st 1986 and the guy that did the
autopsy so I guess they actually did
find this guy's body but um that he had
died from the he had got like septic
shock from the puncturing of the wall by
the states [ __ ] fist man he stuck his
fist up his ass of hers that was like
control oh this is horrifying
all right so what was this guy's
reaction to kill him that guy just
didn't care kept him kept on going yeah
that's what I mean it's just hit like I
said he saw people like bugs I guess
it's like oh I this one's particularly
pretty I'll see how long I can keep this
one alive like while I'm pulling legs
off and stuff it seemed like that kind
of thing I would do that luckily he's
already - like I said he died actually
pretty young would say you know
so the next one happened in spring of
1987 and this was another acquaintance
of his it was a 20 year old guy his name
was Larry Pearson and he met the guy
when Larry came into his shop it was
like oh I really like all your stuff and
I was like you know really into like
wizard type of stuff when I was a kid
know this all you shit's really cool and
everything like that so Larry then ends
up going and staying at bird Ellis house
like as a lodger for a little while and
he couldn't really pay rent but he
started doing like chores and should
around those like washing the dishes and
show like that like around the house is
this a gay guy straight guy um I don't
know okay um I guess probably a lot of
them were hustlers right some of them
like had straight relationships but
would hustle on this
okay so you know it's kind of hard to
say but so yeah so this guy now
according to brunella
he said that he actually wasn't planning
on making a captive out of this guy but
then the guy said something or made a
joke about hustling gay guys and
stealing all their money like he like he
used to do it when he was younger like
back in wichita r whatever and
apparently that made Bernal a mad oh
really he killed gay guys yeah or
something or or or something like that I
don't know if it made him mad but it's
just like he's like a wall I think I'm
gonna take captive too you know taken
captive or this guy too
so that night like the same night that
he said that he injected him with some
kind of drug and then put him down in
the basement and he tied his hands over
his head and then had like he had it
like wrapped around this like brick like
column thing that he had done in his
basement then he did the thing with the
injecting drink later into the lair
annex again then he brings down the
transformer and like starts
electrocuting him now Robert Byrd Ellis
said that Larry Pearson was actually the
most cooperative of his victims because
was something that Bob Rotella would do
is fish because like I said he kept a
lot of them in captivity for quite a
while you know he would say you know I
won't torture you as badly like if you
let me do this then I won't do this
worst thing and all this other kind of
[ __ ] so apparently Larry was kind of
would let him do some stuff just to keep
because he was afraid that he would do
worship later on so um as I said he had
like he had done all these electrical
shocks he had broken a bunch of bones in
his hand with an iron rod he did that
but you know because he was cooperative
they said okay well he's like all right
well I'll move you from the basement
I'll move you up to the second floor and
then if you continue to be good
you know I won't do it as bad you know
what I mean I'll just I mean he'd still
do [ __ ] to him but it just wouldn't be
as bad as before and apparently I guess
what ended up happening was that Larry
was so he got to be like so afraid of
him that at least according to bird Ella
that he learned to sleep without moving
because he didn't want to like move or
snore like do anything that would like
make the guy mad right so he was just
like which is like horrible you know and
bird Ella would say oh a movie back down
to the basement or whatever so now Larry
Pierson was in captivity for six weeks
damn and then after that I mean after
that time period he just like lost it
and he was giving he was giving Bob
Rotella head and bit really hard it is
dick yeah which I was like try to bite
it off yeah and apparently was bad I
mean he had ended up having to go to the
hospital for it thing so so yeah he just
lost it and he he just tried to like you
know but yeah he probably tried about
his day um unfortunately he was
restrained at the time so you know that
wasn't a lot more he could do Bob
Rotella
actually just bludgeoned him with a tree
limb which I don't know why he had a
tree limb around but whatever um so yeah
he bludgeoned him unconscious and then
took a bag and put it over his head and
tied and she suffocated him to death and
then he drove himself to the hospital
for the dick wound because it had if I
guess it needed stitches and she liked
because it was apparently really bad and
he just told him oh you know that it was
consensual but it's like oh he bit me
accidentally or something right so then
after he gets treated for the dick wound
then he goes back to the house cuts up
the kids body puts his head in a plastic
bag in his freezer and then later buried
it out in the backyard
now the other guys Robert Sheldon I
think was the other guy now that guy's
head he kept that in the yard for a
while until it skeletonized and then he
took the skull and
put it in his bedroom closet cuz I guess
he thought it was cool or something yeah
yeah yeah so this guy was all cut up I
feel like I said I think the UM most of
the body parts ended up like in
landfills because he would put them out
for the garbage collection but some of
it but this guy's had he kept and it was
in the yard and it was actually found
later on now here's where his whole
serial killing career starts to unravel
because his last victim who actually got
away was named Christopher Bryson now he
kidnapped Christopher Bryson in March of
1988 it was a 22 year old prostitute so
he lures him to the house he says hey
you know as a client or whatever so
Chris Bryson goes to the house they had
met like at a Greyhound bus station or
something like that so they hang out at
the house and they're hanging out like
in the living room or whatever and he
says oh we should go up to the second
floor you know there's all the dogs are
down here and upstairs there's a couch
and there's a TV and it's all comfy and
let's go up there so he's like all right
fair enough so Chris is walking up the
stairs and while he's walking up the
stairs Bob Rotella whacks him on the
back of the head and knocks him out so
then he has him like tied up to the bed
and this is one of the pictures that I
have and he starts like taking all these
pictures of him like Polaroids and stuff
when he's all like tied up and
unconscious and [ __ ] that's the ones I
saw I think yeah there there's ones of
the other victims too like on Myrna
pedia but I didn't really want to put
them in the show because those guys died
this guy lived so yeah so yeah he starts
taking all his pictures now Chris um was
in there he's in there for four days he
gets beaten with an iron club bird Ella
injects him with various animal
tranquilizers [ __ ] like that like in
various parts of his body puts alligator
clips on his testicles nipples whatever
shocks him rapes him several times a day
you know keep just keeps him tied up
just keeps giving him different drugs
[ __ ] like that
um so he said after he escaped he said
that he would show me pictures of the
other guys that he had done this to and
some of them were dead yeah and he said
this is what's gonna happen to you like
if you don't cooperate so he's like so I
saw a bunch of pictures of like
different people and he would like
threaten me with it um so he also got
Drano injected into his throat and swab
his eyes with alcohol and all this other
kind of [ __ ] now because um I guess
Christopher Bryson had kind of gone
along with him for a little while
because he had gotten a couple of
privileges so even though he was like
you know tied to the bed with several
ropes Byrd Ella would let him watch TV
during the day and he would let him keep
the remote control for the TV like in
between his knees so he could like kind
of get to it's like his hands were tied
up and stuff but he could like get to it
with his knees so on this one particular
day he figures out he's like okay well
I'm gonna escape but he didn't know if
bird Ella was in the house or not so he
had to like like lay there and he's like
trying to turn the TV down and it's like
see if he can hear him and [ __ ] like
that okay okay well even if he is here
I'm gonna try and get the [ __ ] out of
here
turned out he wasn't there lucky for him
alright
so what he did was um he actually I
guess his hands were tied up different
than they normally were so he got one of
his hands out now one of the another
privilege that bird Ella had given him
was he had given him a cigarette and
before he left to run errands he like
threw some matches at him right so Chris
gets one of his hands-free he gets the
matches and lights it and burns off the
other rope and then he gets the [ __ ] out
he jumps out a [ __ ] second-floor
window yeah naked all he had almost like
a dark dog collar was like a rope on it
and he broke his ankle jumping out of
the window and then he runs to the
[ __ ] neighbor's house and the
neighbor obviously doesn't let her this
is a naked man on his porch like I bring
it all the cops so didn't yeah they did
call the cops
he was like I'm not letting you in you
just stand right there and be naked but
um you know I'm gonna call the cops and
everything will be fine so so this guy
escaped and if you see there's like a um
there's a documentary that's going
around I think it's on YouTube I watched
it a while back um it's got James Ellroy
the crime writer he's kind of presenting
it so there's a bunch of [ __ ] about him
on there
but um it's got like a reenactment of
this and it's actually got interviews
with like the real guy as well so yeah
so this guy escaped and he basically
told he was like all [ __ ] up it's like
he had all wounds everywhere his eyes
were all [ __ ] up his throat was all
[ __ ] up I've seen interviews with him
yeah he said the guy would sit there
shocking me just watching ya save a sick
bastard
sit there watching it yeah like go
through the electrocution process what
the hell man it's like some [ __ ] Nazi
doctor experimental [ __ ] you have some
[ __ ] sexual problems so um so Chris
is telling the police all of this stuff
so the cops are like okay well they
decide to put barela's house under
surveillance for a little while and see
if they can you know meanwhile they take
the go to the hospital thankfully and he
gets treated now at first the cops go to
bird Ellis property and he won't let
them in so they have to go back and get
like a search warrant to do the property
and everything and they use that guy's
testimony like to get the search warrant
so then finally they go back with the
search warrant and start looking around
so then while they are looking around
the house unfortunately they didn't find
a lot of bodies at first and they said
the house was like I guess he was kind
of like I don't they didn't really say
he was a hoarder but they said it was
like super cluttered and they said was
like dog [ __ ] everywhere so kind of like
a hoarder yeah um so I mean they did
find like a lot of the photographs but
photograph doesn't necessarily prove
anything because like you can't prove
your that the people
or dead you can't prove that you know
maybe it's an art photograph who knows
so there was a lot of kind of problems
in that area and they really had to like
kind of search around but while they're
searching the house they do find some
stuff that corroborates Christopher
Bryson story they found like some burnt
rope ends like tied to the you know bed
upstairs they find like the transformer
with like the alligator clips tied to it
they find like the pipe and everything
so this kind of you know goes along with
what he told them happened to him over
the previous four days they also noted
that the you know the posts on the bed
there like it looked like you know there
were ropes around it now from where he
had been tied there but he's like the
way it was worn looked like there had
been a lot of people tied to it that had
been like struggling to get free because
it was like really really warmly this
bit was that his banner was an extra bed
you know what I don't know he had sort
of like I said this was a three storey
house so I don't know if he had like a
kind of this is terrible but um I don't
know if he had like a special like a
room yeah cuz he must have a bunch of
that torture room right well like I said
he had a bunch of extra rooms because he
always had like tenants like he had
lodgers like that he let's stay there
you know what I mean so he must have had
a lot of extra bedrooms like I said I've
seen a picture of the house like an old
picture it's not a giant house but it's
like you know it's kind of one of those
old-fashioned Midwestern looking houses
it looks like it has like an attic like
an Oprah of third floor and stuff so the
cops start searching more stringently
through the house and they find a human
skull in a second-floor closet which I
guess was barela's bedroom so yeah so
this was one of the victims now it's not
if you find a human skull in the house
it could just be to be medical medical
or you know you just bought it from a
curio shop or something like that
doesn't necessarily mean anything I'm
just saying in this case obviously a
diamond skull from a curio shop where'd
they get it that's what it's like all
right
but yeah however when they searched the
yard they found a partially decomposed
head yes that's a little harder to
explain oh yeah that's a dead giveaway
right there dead
[Laughter]
we still haven't got around to doing
that Ariel Castro yes I had it on my
list but I just hate ribs with this dude
that girl was in that house that's I'm
still get stuck in my head forever dig
that was like [ __ ] brilliant yeah so
okay so they find a partially decomposed
head as I said so like hair and stuff
like buried in the backyard
they also found a bunch of human
vertebrae that had knife and hacksaw
marks on them also another dead giveaway
found a bunch of human teeth in two
different envelopes so he was keeping
that [ __ ] too
it's like that's what I said that's why
they called him the collector
they also found when they searched the
basement they found like a bunch of saws
and stuff when they luminol the place
they found just blood everywhere even
though he had wipes it up you know
obviously the luminol showed it the
chainsaw that they found on there when
they tested that they found little
gobbets of flesh and pubic hair and
blood and [ __ ] like that on itself
obviously not real stringent about
cleaning up after himself I remember
when this [ __ ] went down man this is all
over Geraldo and everything this sounds
like something her al yeah we're all
done in Bob bordellos house yeah nobody
had that talk show yeah I know I'm just
yeah probably
who else was what else was Maury Povich
days Ricki Lake although she didn't
usually do like a lot of compositing
true crimes now that makes is just a
paternity I'm in love with the dude the
worst diapers yeah
now a stripper that kind of Jerry
Springer Springer
I don't know have you told that story
the show before I remember you I
remember you telling me that though yeah
we used to have this uh
got club that was common underground
golf club it it was a dudes house but it
yeah was a club they had a club had a
bar it had everything in there you know
anybody it wasn't really open to the
public per se you know it was you had to
be invited in and it was called the
convent the rabbi dude named Pierre and
you never knew who was gonna go be who
would be in there it was a [ __ ]
really cool little [ __ ] private club
you know all the Hoff dude he's got
strippers were there and there was you
never really could tell it was nudity
and sometimes sex it was going on but
there was never really a crowd and he
bigger than about 30 people in there
most of them knew each other time I was
in there man turned around
[ __ ] it was Jerry Springer in there
Jerry Springer was sitting down watching
like a couple a couple they were doing
just like light body this is very light
you know the main [ __ ] there's just more
bullshitting and he sleeps there back in
there but yeah yes he's sitting there in
a big ol wicker wicker back chair and
[ __ ] you know the gold [ __ ] grin on
his face and just Jerry [ __ ] Springer
you know there
who the [ __ ] Joe invites Jerry Springer
to a guy experimented with Jerry
Springer was in the French Quarter all
the time as the French Quarter New
Orleans he was in those days he was
there all the time and I said Jerry
Springer man how you doing you know I
was [ __ ] decked out you know I was my
first wife you know and he's like uh how
you doing man on cuz how you need to say
hi and that's just you enjoy the show oh
man this place is great man he's talking
us is like you show me real fun you know
yeah gary oldman was in there two one
time well hey I'd be a lot more excited
Trent Reznor didn't use Marilyn Manson
didn't get in they wouldn't let him in
he was [ __ ] pissed
that's very [ __ ] pissed didn't you say
that one time Trent Reznor drove off in
a jar
yeah it's like this is my head Lac
we were up on the and nobody liked him
he he had the image of kind of like a
goth industrial guy but when he was hang
out in the club he was just wearing
Bermuda shorts and a baseball cap and
like God you sure let's see one of those
guys one of those kind of Gotham yeah
yeah you know actually what it was is
where oh god [ __ ] the suit that I'm just
making money off it he's really kind of
it seemed like he was like that a little
bit right a little bit at the Andrew
eldritch yeah like an Andrew although I
feel like Andrew I just kind of grew out
of that what did he do he left him and
Marilyn Manson lived in town they had
just moved there yeah I remember having
like a bad place man it's like in the
French Quarter was fun but boy it
Marilyn Manson tell you in his book that
if you're gonna go to the French Quarter
and hang out in New Orleans you're gonna
end up in one of three places a bar a
cemetery or prison and that is
absolutely true
it worries pop easy bright if you don't
believe yeah yeah it had a certain
allure to it but it was like a black
hole once you went in you could kind of
get stuck again you trapped there
yeah lots of crime lots of lots of bad
[ __ ] going on and not a good scene but
was funny you know I've told you know
about convergence that was happened yeah
that was a time where those goth kids
killed that family that was around that
same convergence remember we did a show
about that no we're gonna do it oh we
haven't we haven't done one yet we're
talking about it cuz I have it written
on the list we just haven't got around
to it yet yeah I was because you knew
that you knew that kids lawyer yeah well
no that was forgot Farrell oh that's
right Rob knew that I mean a kid at work
that his lawyer
Osama the ones that killed the Christian
family and stole their oh right thought
we did be a show on now we didn't I
don't think so yeah unless no maybe we
talked about it on unsolved mystery no
they were heading to they were heading
to New Orleans because that's right it
was convergence we must have talked
about that as convergence or I don't
think we did a whole show about and I
was there and all the people that I knew
from Boston up in Iran right Man Ray you
know from the club yeah I'm reading this
and that that old scene you know like
acts Club hacks you know they they
showed up in New Orleans and hadn't seen
them in a few years and it's just this
it was a cool time but it was not
sustainable nobody it's not as cool as
it used to be
no it was only like that for a while and
Katrina hit and destroyed all that yeah
and in some ways I feel like some of
this [ __ ] was cool cuz a lot of people
like talked about how cool New York City
was like the work got gentrified and
stuff like that but yeah it's like that
I'm sure it was like cool to a point but
it's also like well that really
dangerous yeah exactly
like he gets shot and drive man like
when I was living in Detroit back in the
[ __ ] Cure days before I join the army
laid out in the late 80s you know Sophie
she came to visit me you know she's been
going to City Club and all the old club
that I used to go to she says they're
still going pretty good but there was
something about the late 80s and the
goth scene in that area at that time it
was it was all kind of like it was the
right time to be there you know which I
happen to be in the right time to be in
all those places in LA yeah I didn't I
miss California New York I wasn't there
for that you know but like the fall in
the Batcave yeah yeah I'm from
California but I moved away didn't want
to live there anymore you know but I got
to see all the other cool [ __ ] I'm happy
yeah and now that we're here Orlando's
now [ __ ] kind of blow it up so yeah
you wouldn't think it because I think a
lot of people think floor that's like
but there's actually a really big yeah I
mean the Orlando Tampa cuz you know
we're not the Tampa far apart Orlando
Tampa is like a huge gothic in the 90s
and in the nineties Tampa was one of the
biggest the castle was one of the
biggest clubs if not it probably is and
you can go back to like Saturday Night
Live and in the 90s wind you know what
was her name the girl that did Buffy the
Vampire Slayer yeah doing golf talk she
was always talking about how much how
Morgoth Tampa was versus Orlando and we
know exactly what they're talking about
they're talking that is that it's true
they're talking about [ __ ] the castle
okay or in a big or high bar yeah so
they're talking about and actually I
mean the castle is still like the
dominant force that's been there
I don't even remember how long tonight I
lived over there while a lot of our
friends and she does a lot of fliers for
that but um they've opened up a bunch of
new places now like a lot of new venues
they have like all kind of shows the
others they have crowbar the Orpheum
guichen have to have all that stuff so
but you know Orlando is opened a bunch
of [ __ ] - so we're doing okay over here
we even get like sometimes when we do or
memento mori' like on Monday nights of
third Mondays and month we get people
coming from over there good thing there
used to be [ __ ] going on in Savannah
even yes savannah actually used to be
alright also I don't know if it's still
you know I haven't heard much about it
lately you know I feel like stan is
beautiful it really is yeah I bet I've
only very honest but yeah very gothic
[ __ ] cemeteries and underground
[ __ ] maybe we should go that's not
that far yeah about what like a six
seven-hour drive not even before I don't
even think it's that far if you go there
we should just fly true okay my sister
lives in Atlanta yeah yeah hmm ask her
how long it takes I've driven to Atlanta
from Daytona and it took six hours but
it's I don't know do show from there
there's some there's some under there's
some abandoned subway systems in Atlanta
already in Savannah
yeah there's a whole abandoned
underground I think they tour in certain
places ooh that would be awesome yeah
like I said that that might be a good
place to go for making trains it's not
that far away and it's like train
stations from the 1800s and stuff yeah
underneath the ground subway stations
I'd be kind of red yeah all right
so okay yeah what's happening with this
what's happening with this okay so as I
said they you know they found all the
blood they found the head they found all
this other stuff in his house they also
found over 300 polaroid pictures and
about 30 different snapshot photos of
various
males in some of them appeared alive
some of them appear dead some of them
have never been identified so some of
them might still be alive they were
trying to like identify all of them and
like match them with missing people they
also found like a whole bunch of you
know porn needles all kind of crammed
like that he had a book about drugs like
how to administer them and how much you
needed
they also found his [ __ ] little
tortured notebook yeah now they're
trying to like - safer like all of his
little like codes and [ __ ] in there now
he had stuff like you know if he put B F
that thank you but yes but yeah yeah
yeah anal penetration like it's like to
put it in a nice way your fleece
johnsoning someone as a booty warrior
yeah I guess and then he would put like
fing s like furred sticking his finger
up your ass yeah he'd also put things
like carrot F or cucumber F yeah he also
put like you know how much like I said
how much of a dosage of the medicine or
whatever medicine it was and how much he
gave it to him like how long how far
apart it was you know so he would put D
see that usually meant no that meant
drain cleaner EK or EKG that meant
electrocution you know so all that other
kind of stuff and and as I was saying
before he would make little comments
like gag loose no resistant retie he
would say things like that likes so he
was like really meticulous something
he's trying to make this [ __ ] official
yeah that's exactly what it sounds like
a year of an air of a [ __ ] scientist
of a scientific explanation right he's
trying to elevate himself yeah I really
really do get that cuz like I said he
had this whole thing about oh I'm so
smart and I collect all these antiques
from all over the world and sell them to
you and I'm like so much better than you
are
so I feel like he was like putting on
airs yeah as he was like he was trying
to be like [ __ ] Hannibal Lecter
yeah like that was how he was and it was
almost like his he was under control
yeah it was rational yeah like it was I
think it was a way to of like putting
himself at one remove from it also
because he was like I said it was like
an experimental subject it's just like a
rat probably gonna cut open yourself an
air of authority
yeah exactly exactly so you know it's
horrible okay so anyway so they ended up
identifying like some of the missing men
from the photos because some of the
dudes had been reported missing
obviously like I said they only found a
couple of the bodies you know including
the one head and they found a skull a
lot of them have not been found they
think they were like in a landfill
they also found like a whole bunch of
names in the book and you know they
assumed that probably he had killed
those as well now all they know is that
probably they think he killed six men
now they're not you know it's not
without the bounds of possibility that
he probably killed more than that but
those are the ones he admitted to you
know I mean it was just six and then the
last guy was the seventh but he escaped
now he ended up going to I mean they
ended up like after they arrested him
and [ __ ] like they ended up having to
like take naked pictures of him like to
like match up to because a problem that
they ran into with a lot of the photos
of the victims that they found in his
house was that his face was never in
them like he there would be pictures of
him like raping his victims and things
like that but obviously his face was
never in them so they had to take all
these pictures of him naked from like
every single angle so they could like
match them up yeah
like here this the curve of your ass
looks just like like oh can you imagine
like that's not a good I know but it's
like goodbye moles well I know that but
it's it just seemed you know it but they
don't know it they do it through like
moles they look at a photograph they say
well these three moles and guys elbow
and they look oh yeah he's got them
little bitty identifiers it just kind of
it just seems like I would not want that
job yeah I'm just saying yeah any any
you need PC your body can be identified
well yeah and I mean I'd be super easy
because I have like freckles all over
yeah there's all kind of stuff they do
and I I have a witches they got that
[ __ ] down
to a damn they got that [ __ ] you got
away a witch's teat what's it a mole oh
you know what I mean yeah like one of
those like big like 3d moles yeah I
guess so that's not
no but I'm just like no if you if it was
back in the old days they would have
said that's where the devil suckles yeah
I would have got burned at the stake
[Laughter]
anyway so initially because they
couldn't find a lot of evidence and
stuff so they only at first they only
charged him with one murder that of
Larry Pearson because that was the head
that they found so you know they could
establish that that was who did that so
they're gonna do him for that and then
they were actually going to give him I
think he ended up getting charged with
two counts of first-degree murder and
four counts of second-degree murder
along with a bunch of other charges like
for sodomy kidnapping all that other
kind of stuff now they wanted to give
him the death penalty but they allowed
him to plea out they said we will not go
you know we will not seek the death
penalty if you will tell us everything
that you did you know to the victims and
tell us where the bodies aren't [ __ ]
like that obviously they couldn't find
the bodies because most of them he said
that he sent them to the landfill
because he put them out with the garbage
so they never did find a show you the
second all these second [ __ ] really
super special ways to getting rid of
bodies that dudes are done my [ __ ]
Dahmer do man acid not can you just
throw out like you know what I mean I'm
not a serial killer obviously but it's
like since I write about a lot of these
gadgets Apple it does seem like the
simplest ways are sometimes the best
it's like sometimes either put the [ __ ]
out with the garbage yeah or as long as
no one sees you obviously or just dump
it in the woods like off a highway
somewhere it's like even if somebody
finds it
they're not gonna tie it back to you you
know what I mean don't teach anybody
some [ __ ] we're just saying I'm just
saying we're just saying but yeah so it
just goes to show me we put most of
these bodies out with the garbage and
they still have they never found I mean
all you gotta do is just listen to this
show and talk about all the cases and
everything that she's written about the
more extravagant a [ __ ] case is seems
like the more you're gonna get caught
that's what I mean the more complicated
there's the more moving parts you have
to your plan the more it's gonna burn a
the Dumber it is the [ __ ]
you know the bigger the chances are you
gonna get away with it yeah I can't
overthink it evidently yeah I feel like
most of the I mean most of the cases
that I write about which are almost all
unsolved cases a lot of them are just
somebody that's like they just grab
somebody off the side of the road like a
prostitute or just somebody walking home
to the store or with something like that
and just kill them and just dumped him
off a [ __ ] road somewhere they drive
down the road and just dump them out the
car and they never found out who did it
never yeah you never hear about it again
yeah it's like people you know people
found the body but there was no way to
like link it that almost kind of like it
did it if you make a big if you if you
make a big deal out of it and give this
thing a [ __ ] fantastic signature it
skyrockets to the top yeah pile and
you're more likely to get caught it's
weird yeah it definitely is
but yes now crime is sticking out from
the other ones from the other ones
because depressingly I mean you know
crime has gone down a lot but you know
and since the 90s but you know there's
still a lot and a lot of them are never
solved because that's amazing you can
just take your body and cut it out in
pieces and throw it out in the garbage
but it makes sense because there's so
much so that always did kind of make
sense to me but no one's gonna look yeah
they're not looking and there's so many
other pieces of meat in that garbage
that's why I mean all the dinners and
old leftovers and stuff like that yeah
it's that that's why I'm surprised
people don't do it more often
right maybe they do and they're just not
getting caught maybe that's what it is
maybe I'll just jerk off they tried to
grind bodies up and flush them down the
toilet
he thought that he's being really slick
there that was a Nelson wouldn't yeah
but then all I did just clog them it's a
clock that was everybody's like hey is
that [ __ ] smell coming from yeah
yeah that's dumbass price should have
just thrown it out thrown it out yeah
yeah because you just try to flush it
down the toilet it's not gone it's still
like go so my pit goes somewhere and
it'll get backed up it'll either get
backed up in your piper will get backed
up in the like sewer like down the
street you gonna get out of the house
remember it was dead no it didn't
because he was on the top floor yeah and
the pipe that went down extra and it
just got clogged and started thinking
yep so dumbass yeah he was well he was
also keeping bodies like wrapped like in
a blanket like in his [ __ ] yeah
these dentists you see have any memory
have like all those little [ __ ] air
fresheners like sitting on it air
freshener was like this little those
little old ones that used to blow apart
like that this [ __ ] never smell like
I've grown up as a little kid you find
dead when I was a kid you'd find dead
dogs on the side of garbage track very
nice Don the size of the railroad tracks
and you don't know you can you just
can't comprehend how much that the small
dog would [ __ ] stick and how far you
could you could smell that dog you're
gonna put a person yeah a person times
bigger yeah and let that rot in your
house and you think you're gonna [ __ ]
mask that odor with a few [ __ ] air
fresheners you're [ __ ] [ __ ] sorry
yeah I find stupid well that and he's
scared to throw it away but he's not
afraid to let it [ __ ] decomposed it
decompose in his claws I kind of feel
like they're into it they have to be
into it it's like Dahmer it's like what
you have to be like into like rotting
decaying because how could you stand it
otherwise I think it's fear I don't know
[ __ ] man I'm just like sometimes I'm
walk doing by walk down the walking path
and like like you know like if a little
raccoon or a little possum or some
run-over in the road you can hear it
using that mallet like 500 600 yards
away and it's like you have to hold your
breath yeah just something that small so
you can imagine how many worse the
[ __ ] human body smells make you want
to puke yeah it's just like a horrible
gagging Dahmer had a bunch of them up in
his head that's what I mean I can't
imagine what that would have smell just
you can't get used to that no yeah but
yeah so anyways so this guy like I said
they allowed him to plead out and so you
know he still got like multiple life
sentences but they said okay well we
won't give you the death penalty if you
like confess to everything that you did
so he did like I said a lot of the stuff
that I said about what he did all the
victims that was his confession like he
said that he did all that stuff and as I
said he one blamed the victims for being
like well they didn't really appreciate
it I was trying to help them get out of
prostitution or drug use or whatever the
[ __ ] he said he was trying to do he also
said that he was mad that people didn't
understand that he was a
sensitive citizen who made mistakes yeah
that's a mistake I mean you know he was
very sensitive we all make mistakes he
made mistakes I mean that's every day
he's torchic's
he's raping and tortured dudes of death
yeah oops my bad mr. dissident I was you
know I'm very sensitive and I made some
mistakes I won't put this [ __ ]
huh I'm gonna put him above Dahmer
no no Dahmer above BTK BTK
but above Dennis Rader cuz Dennis Rader
said some [ __ ] with crazy [ __ ] too
but this is even crazy I mean do doing
all that and then actually standing him
up in front of other people and just
saying you made mr. may mistake see oh
did you is that what you must sensitive
person I've made mistakes people will
believe anything and [ __ ] like
this think that people would believe him
it's like man I've got you know it's
like I've got drunk and wrote the wrong
amount like on the tab at the bar thing
that's a mistake thing please napping a
guy keeping him tied to the bed for two
weeks injecting Drano into his neck and
fisting him today is not just a mistake
punch [ __ ] the [ __ ] ass
notic nips just yeah yeah sorry yeah it
won't happen again accepted yeah yeah
what the [ __ ]
so um oh and also I need to set this
[ __ ] on fire right at least he's
already dead yeah um yeah oh that movie
summer we're gonna sew him inside a bear
suit so I'm making a mistake here yeah I
got the lighter oh woops Nick oh man I'm
very sorry man I'm very sensitive man
and I make I didn't mean to do that
and he also um since he was blaming
everyone but himself
he also blamed the cops for not catching
him earlier
so oh yeah yeah put it on that man put
it on law enforcement well it's your
fault you should copy yeah yeah he
genuinely seemed to believe that he was
just like this upstanding citizen
that's just like oh I messed up a couple
things and now you all are being sent
mean to me yeah like stop me and that's
on you guys you guys didn't stop me in
time yeah I'm just so glad the students
dead
alright so now prior to in the in the
1990s the early 1990s he is starting
right it started writing letters to his
ministers I guess he was still kind of
marginally a Catholic and he was saying
that the prison officials were not
giving him his heart medication because
obviously he'd had high blood pressure
serviced entire life and needed
medication and he claimed that they were
not giving it to him and he was like
complaining about anything he's gonna
see when all this other kind of stuff
well uh actually on October 8 1992 he
died of a heart attack he was 43 years
old yeah young man well they were trying
to save mine well his dad died of a
heart attack when he was 39 so it might
not like run in the family right now you
know were the prison officials not
giving him his heart medication can I
care that much about it not really um
you know what I mean I don't know if
that's true though because I feel like
he's kind of a little bit of a Fanta
cyst yeah and I kind of feel like he has
a little persecution complex things like
they're not yet what could be okay but
it could be could be I mean it could be
that the people who live there were like
man [ __ ] right because if she's got he's
got a life sentence you don't mean it
[ __ ] that dude it should be said that
after he died the judge that presided
over his trial when they told it hey
that guy died the judge said and I quote
couldn't have happened to a nicer guy
which I was like I kinda wanted to
high-five him for that that's pretty
cool yeah I hear that [ __ ] makes me want
to smack the dude that [ __ ] tried
tried what
his name [ __ ] never member Oh Bundy
buddy yeah he's like I don't know well I
don't know where he went wrong son you'd
have made a great lawyer
he's look at that dude like he was
sucking yeah like oh what a shame he
made a mistake he was kissing Bundy's
ass he made a mistake he was kissing he
just killed like a whole bunch of men I
don't know where you went in the band we
would have made a great lawyer you could
have been up here yeah he let them down
to the legs sympathetic yeah what the
like oh man out of bitch-slap that
[ __ ] judge right what the [ __ ] I can
believe that like we would so we were
watching the the Bundy tapes on Netflix
I know I saw that I was like oh my god
it's like that's [ __ ] unbelievable I
think Jenni and I know we party with
lawyers and stuff and I've worked for
[ __ ] lawyers you know defense lawyers
and a lot of times you know prosecute
you know prosecutors can become defense
lawyers and they did this and then
elections happen and these same
[ __ ] can become judges the man
there are a lot of lawyers are weird I'm
just gonna say lawyers are weird
I don't understand why countries wanna
elect lawyers into power for you know
politicians I don't believe lawyers
should be politicians leaders should be
politicians you can get those from other
professions then you can let lawyers
manage what the leaders do well I mean I
think lawyers don't give lawyers it's a
necessary job in our society but to be a
good lawyer you've got to be a sociopath
there you have to be a good bullshitter
they lie and they don't believe in truth
yeah they just believe how they can spin
things everything that's their job
that's their spin I mean you know I'm
not [ __ ] on that's what the best
literally with their job lawyer ISM is a
game yeah and man don't give those
[ __ ] authority not outside a
courtroom just in a courtroom just
saying if you [ __ ] intellect lawyers
just leaders you're gonna [ __ ] live
in a world of [ __ ] interpretation
where you're living in a world of gray
and one one guy interprets it one way
and the other guys going to there is no
truth truth is just what we interpret
and those [ __ ] laugh
they send an innocent dude to [ __ ]
jail I'm a great lawyer I put an
innocent guy in jail I'm a great lawyer
I got a murderer off that's [ __ ] how
they [ __ ] day like I said that's what
their job is
that's literally I I don't [ __ ] don't
trust lawyers outside a courtroom I
don't trust anyone for any reason just
you know no you're much better electing
some kind of a military leader you know
and you let the system keep him in check
at least he's gonna tell you what he
thinks
at least he's gonna do what he thinks is
right a lawyer doesn't think anything's
right it's just they just think about
what they can get away with and what
they can convince other people
now I'm not an insult and lawyers that
are here there are some good lawyer well
like I said that's what those I party
with lawyers and you lawyers that are
listening to me know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about it's a [ __ ] game it's
just the same thing as the priesthood
the old priesthood really the preet they
would interpret the the Word of God to
be whatever they wanted it to be at the
moment really and argue about it
whatever was gonna give them the most
yeah stuff at the moment yeah yeah so
after this douchebag died they actually
had they auctioned off his house and all
of his antiques and stuff because he
apparently had all bunch of stuff ended
up raising about a horned $27,000
although a lot of that went to his legal
fees they actually this guy this
businessman from Kansas City Missouri
named Eldon Meier bought the guy's house
and he said oh well I didn't have any
like interest in him specifically but I
understood him which I was like hmm
let's put that guy in a washer on a
watch list but he actually had the house
torn down and I think he sold half of
the property like to each person on
either side of the house so I'm like I'm
not sure if I'd want that land or not
it's like I've had [ __ ] heads in it
who knows there's probably other [ __ ]
bones in there too it's like yeah I'm
hiccuping yeah I see that I'm fighting
it so yeah like I said if you want
there's a documentary about this called
bizarre bizarre sometimes called James
Ellroy presents bizarre bizarre you know
it's and it's very funny because it has
James Ellroy he's very hard-boiled and
he's like talking about what a scumbag
this dude is look at the beginning and I
just thought it was very funny this
whole show is becoming rogues yeah well
[ __ ] bags are way more fun to talk yeah
that's the nature of this show and this
is the entertainment you know this is
this is the way Entertainment is and
this is also education we're teaching
you guys how bad these [ __ ] can
be and yeah it's bad [ __ ] man if I can
watch your back but you also gotta learn
to laugh at this kind of [ __ ] because if
it gets to you then you can't enjoy life
yeah you should get to you too much I
mean it is rare that's why we're talking
like how I try to think cuz I write
about this [ __ ] yeah
10 hours a day I have but if it was
everywhere you'd be used to it and you
wouldn't care because you would know all
about this but people are [ __ ] drawn
to it because this is very because it's
unusual is something that doesn't impact
Pete most people your day-to-day life
it's extreme behavior yeah but if you
think back over our shows and then we've
talked about these dudes all give off
warning signs mm-hmm
the average person wouldn't come in
contact with this guy I mean dude hung
out with bomb junkies yeah
and in you know in some kind of weird
really two-bit a homosexual underground
I mean this is the bottom of the gay
scene real gay dudes are in fantastic
[ __ ] clubs making a [ __ ] ton of money
okay [ __ ] dancing they got good taste
and [ __ ] yeah that's how about they're
not piece [ __ ] well I said a lot of
these were just like teenagers homeless
[ __ ] see because probably especially
back in that time and and I know I've
written about a few cases you know where
this happened particularly you know
especially back in the 50s 60s 70s you
came out as gay you got kicked out your
house they didn't care if you were 14
years old and so a lot of them ended up
on the street yeah whether they wanted
to or not and then they would end up
having to turn the prostitution because
they didn't have any other way to make
money so I feel like but that's like
another level because he's like just
taking advantage of you know of these
people too but even in but even in the
eighties the average gay
and it had his [ __ ] wherewithal
[ __ ] would have nothing to do with
these dudes yeah like I said this is
well it's not the normal it's just kind
of like the thing you know it's the same
kind of thing as like serial killers
that target prostitute because they're
you know it's easy they're just on the
street they'll get in your car with you
and most street people aren't into that
that's just a [ __ ] that's the dregs
yeah well like I said it's um it's
somebody that I mean this guy was
obviously not a millionaire or anything
like that but he had a house and he had
he could hold kind of a business yeah
and he could like loan the money and
give them food when they didn't yeah
that's exactly it and then like I said I
feel like because he never made anything
of himself even though like I feel like
he felt like he should have but he could
have power over these powerless little
kids pretty much I mean they were just
teenagers most of them yeah so I feel
like that was where he was coming from
ya know there was also a movie that came
out in 2009 just called bird Ella but I
haven't seen it I don't know if it's any
good so if any of you guys have seen it
this but it's you know obviously based
on this douche bag so if anybody has
seen it let me know if it's any good cuz
I kind of want to check it out but you
know I didn't get around to it before
the show alright so we are going to wrap
up the show about Robert Byrd Ella aka
the Kansas City butcher aka the
collector hope you guys sort of enjoyed
it you know even if enjoyed and you know
Tom is still a fairly coherent fairly
coherent I'm just hoping that the next
show will be something that is not so
dark as so the presence of the moment
well the next one we're gonna do that
cult nexium cult know about next thing
called yeah so that's still tournament
that's still kind of depressing cuz it's
like a science nobody got killed in that
one though as far as I know was as far
as we know yeah we'll see anything that
sign it that seemed to be kind of like
consensual weirdos I think maybe well
I'm not so sure about that yeah well you
could say Scientology's consensual you
can break in that you could probably go
go to a science not for that not for the
kids born into today
Scientology prisons that they have
what's it called gold base yeah and go
right into that Scientology prison where
Mike render and other guys I forgotten
thinking in my career I forgot with and
and you couldn't break him out of prison
like oh no this is my religious decision
to be in this prison you know that's how
weird they were yeah they're like that
that's bad when you got no I'm gonna
stay here in this religious I don't
understand like I might get into this a
little bit more when we do the show
about that cult next week but it's like
I don't understand like I'm not gonna
[ __ ] on anybody that needs like any kind
of self-help type of [ __ ] cuz I notice
that people are into that yeah um but
and I'm seriously I'm not the most like
psychologically stable person ever but
please do I don't I just have never
understood that the desire for that
because I feel like here's the thing
you're already telegraphing you got a
weakness when you show up I'll tell you
that well one that too and I don't like
to do that but to it's like how does a
person who does not know me know what I
should do or know what is best for me
nobody's me but me what they're gonna do
is they're gonna do a process similar to
the military yeah I know where they're
gonna [ __ ] put you in a bunch of
stress and yeah they're gonna remove
they're gonna mosey down and build you a
that's a good that's you that's every
cult does that every of the military and
you're doing this to you know look I
went through that I [ __ ] loved it
okay because I understood what the
process was yeah but what you're doing
to a 19 year old or an 18 year old kid
you don't mean to get him ready for
military duty it's totally justifiable
what they're doing UK yeah because
that's like a means to an end
yeah I understand it in the military
capacity you cannot have a bunch of
dudes that sit around and have to have
[ __ ] blow pops and [ __ ] have to do
that you have to or if you want to like
go off and do their own [ __ ] and they
gotta watch [ __ ] they got it they have
to work as a damn how to do what they're
told you're gonna have [ __ ] in there
the Hat people will get killed Captain
Crunch cereal if they don't have Captain
Crunch cereal then they can't
how you gonna send a dude in combat
where he can't function with that
Captain Crunch cereal you can't so you
have to knock all this I gotta have my
cartoons you got to knock all that [ __ ]
out of them
ya know yeah and and make them grow up
cuz some of these kids
from families where there were you know
improper parenting or no father you know
no father figure so they don't have any
adult skills you know see a lot of them
do you know but some of them don't so
military training actually ensures you
not I mean that the that the new soldier
has what he needs to continue his
mission if you don't don't know well
yeah I know that I'm just saying I don't
know I don't know why like anyone would
subject themselves to something like
Scientology or anything like that I just
don't understand it
well because one I you know I wouldn't
because I hate being told what to do
it's like my least favorite thing ever
I'm nice twenty I my spine to you I'm
not gonna explain my mansplain a person
joined Scientology for the same reason a
dude joints a [ __ ] karate dojo
yeah there's yeah there's a elemental
LARPing in the [ __ ] I don't okay
something you know he got his ass
whipped so he's gonna go to the dojo and
he's gonna become a [ __ ] ninja okay
that's the thinking all right now how is
he gonna become a ninja well he's gonna
become a ninja the easiest way he can
can become a ninja the guys are gonna
sell him all this kind of [ __ ] if
it's a [ __ ] up
dojo we're it's gonna they're gonna
teach him a one-inch Death Punch or some
[ __ ] like that and then when he gets
done with that he'll feel better that he
can he can take out a minute five times
his size with a [ __ ] touch this is
the plot of this movie the art of
self-defense but my research on that
[ __ ] no sir that's exactly what it is
it's very much kind of like Eugene
Sandow is a method of becoming a big
[ __ ] using five pound weights
you can't do it well that's just like
every you know every um infomercial that
you ever saw on late-night TV it's like
everything like every weight-loss
product every everything because
everybody wants something easy I'm just
gonna buy this one pill and it's gonna
fix it and it's gonna fix it
and it's gonna be easy I'm gonna buy
this one kitchen
and it's gonna fix it and and and once I
buy it and it's not gonna fit I don't
have to worry about it ever again yes
yeah [ __ ] ain't gonna fix nothing
later [ __ ] it's always throwing
obstacles up and frame I'm not saying
you should be like pessimistic or
nothing cuz I'm not but I'm just saying
you have to understand that your whole
entire life is just gonna be an uphill
struggle it's like when you're at the
beach and the waves keep crashing over
your face and you have to just keep
swimming out it's just like that your
whole entire life and that's how it's
gonna be till you die Eugene Sandow made
a [ __ ] living off of [ __ ] being an
old tiny strong man in the early
nineteen hundred's lifting these heavy
ass [ __ ] weights in front of a live
crowd that was just amazed at this dude
okay he was huge for his time and he
sold them little five-pound weights and
told them if you read this book with
this little five-pound weight you'll be
as strong as me they bought those
weights when thinking they went home
maybe they did it a couple times they
forgot all about it yeah that's exactly
what happened well it made his money Wow
okay it's just like every single like
exercise equipment company it's like
every time New Year's comes around and
everybody makes a resolution negative
vibes I'm gonna work out so they buy it
they spend like you know five hundred
dollars buying a size bike or something
use it a couple times in the never yeah
and they say how easy it is they give
them the [ __ ] easiest [ __ ] thing
to do is just keep doing that
ya know you know one might say Oh God
big four who listen they lifted heavy
[ __ ] weights he worked he worked out
fine everyday exercise product and this
is going back to like the late eighties
or early nineties like one of those
infomercials my favorite one was like
the step aerobics thing and it was basic
it was just like a plastic block and
they was like you just stepped up on a
step down stepped up on it step down
yeah but I was and the thing was like
1999 or how much it was I'm like can you
just not do that with a dictionary yeah
why do you need to buy that you can put
a cinder block over there that's not you
could do that was literally anything
because that is good like doing step so
if you do enough of it but you don't
need to pay $19.99 for this specially
molded like no aqua colored like plastic
thing in the model that's doing it of
course it's probably physically fit
[ __ ] gorgeous yeah they get fitness
model students didn't get fit do you
have
[ __ ] [ __ ] now well it's just like all
the people that they put in the like the
the weight-loss pill commercials every
day they don't use that [ __ ] nope
don't fall for that that's what all
those cults are yeah that's exactly what
it is it's it's the same thing it's
snake oil yep they're just selling you
snake oil yeah they think that it will
make your life easier they don't you
know it doesn't
nothing will you just have to like
powered through man just like everybody
else does we're all in the same boat
yeah and on that note we are ending
episode 155 hope you guys enjoyed it
again if you'd like to support the show
you can go to our patreon page or you
can go to our blog 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a little
button in the sidebar that it goes to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation it'd be very much
appreciated also we have a Zazzle store
a couple people have been asking about
that we have like t-shirts and stuff
there's a link down in the description
we're also gonna start doing our own
screen printed shirts and do an eBay
store we're doing it already
we just haven't got around to putting up
shirts on this story we just gave out to
our patrons last time but uh yeah so
that'll do it for this episode we will
see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]